>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Good
morning.
This is such an exciting
morning for us.  My name is
Sridhar Ramaswamy.  I run the
Ads and Commerce team here at
Google.
Music occupies a really
special place in all of our
hearts.  We all remember our
lives by our favorite
melodies and the times when
we
we heard them.
The time when Roja first came
out, I distinctly remember as
a time that my life with my
fiancee, my wife, then was
forming.  So music really
touches all of us in ways
that are incredibly perm and
personal
and special.
And the people who create
this music literally can move
entire countries and
generations.
And A.R. Rahman is one of the
world's most renowned
musicians.  And when I heard
that he was visiting the
area, the first thing, of
course, I did was buy tickets
for me and my wife to see his
concert this evening.  And I
am very excited about that.
And then when I was given the
opportunity to actually have
him here, have him be in
front of all of you, I jumped
at that opportunity.  And,
you know, it's going to be
quite an amazing time.
A.R. Rahman is, of course, as
I said, one of the world's
most famous, most renowned
moo sigses, known
musicians, known for his
unique style of blending
instruments, performers,
working with people across
the world.
His accomplishments are also
stunning.  He, of course, has
won two Academy Awards, two
grammy awards, and in
addition, he's won four
national music awards in
India, 15 film for music
awards, and 13 film for south
India music awards.
And while he's an amazing
musician, he's also a deep
humanist that has contributed
heavily to the cause of
impoverished women and
children.  And he's also
started the K.M.
conservatory.  This was in
2008, to help aspiring
musicians reach their true
potential.
And it's my incredible
privilege, honor, and
pleasure to have A.R. on
stage with us today.
Please give him a big round
of applause.
[ Applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome.
[ Applause ]
Welcome to Google.  We are so
delighted to have you here.
We have about a 500 Googlers
here, and we also have a live
stream on YouTube that tons
of people are watching.
We'll get you the stats on
how many people are watching.
I know my mom is watching
from Austin.
[ Laughter ]
And I thought, you know, I
would kick this off with a
few questions.
But before that, I was told
by your team that you
actually wanted to be,
believe it or not, a computer
engineer when he was growing
up.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I am happy to say that
Google's loss is the world's
gain.  So we're very happy
you decided not to be a
computer engineer.
But in case you change your
mind, if you decided to be,
we will keep a spot reserved
for you, and that you can
have this --
[ Cheers and applause
]
>>A.R. Rahman: Thank you.
I'm very, very pleased to be
here.  And nice to see all of
you.
I don't get up in the morning
normally, but I had to do
especially for --
[ Laughter ]
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: So this
is someone who will make all
of our engineers proud.
I asked him, you know, where
do you come from?  He said he
flew over from L.A. this
morning.  And I said, okay,
you must have gotten up
early.  When did you go to
sleep?  He said, normally, I
sleep by 4:30.  And so it's
really early for him.  And
it's quite a treat for us.
You know, you have an
incredible musical style that
blends traditional, modern,
religious, and uses so many
different, you know,
instruments.
Where do you draw the
inspiration for this kind of
music?  And how do you bring
it all together?
>>A.R. Rahman: I grew up
listening to various kind of
music, and nobody told me
what to listen to.  So when I
started composing, it was a
part of my pallet.  It was
not negsal, I'm going to do a
beat here or a -- it came
naturally.
And it felt right.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: And,
you know, when you're
thinking about composing, how
does this music come to you?
Is it something that you sit
quietly to imagine?  Or do
you think about a situation
and the Melody flows into
your head?
What is that like?
>>A.R. Rahman: I come from
various sensibilities,
because I was playing with
the southern Indian composers
before.  And I knew how the
tunes would be, kind of.
Then I did commercials.  So
in commercials, it's always,
like, how do you catch the
listener in five seconds, ten
seconds, how do you make a
tune memorable.  Constant --
today, you look at them, and
as if they want to say
something new and say the
same thing.  It should be
catchy, it should be
memorable.
I said, okay, I know that.
For three years, and then I
got sick of it.
And when movies came in, when
I started scoring movies, all
these things were in my head.
So I used parts of different
ideas from different
experiences.
Then later, now, after 20
years, I feel like I should
move on.  And since I have a
classical conservatory back
in chennai, to write more
pieces with more depth in it
so people can play on piano
and write.  There's still
time for that, I guess.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy:
Speaking of movies, you know,
you composed amazing scores.
But the whole process just
seems so very daunting, of
composing a score for an
entire music that is two
hours long.  You know, for us
nonmusicians, you know, here,
how do you even begin to
think about, you know, a
process like that?  Do you
work closely with the
director and producer to get
a feel for what the story is?
How does this all, like, come
together from beginning to
end?  It seems like such a
Mammoth undertaking.
>>A.R. Rahman: It's simple,
yet complicated.
First of all, you go into
what the movie needs.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Yep.
>>A.R. Rahman: And sometimes
you go with it, and sometimes
you go against it.  Because
if that kind of movie has
come before, then you try a
different treatment.      And
that treatment makes the
whole movie newer.
So the various attributes we
sit and brainstorm and get to
a position where, okay, let's
treat this movie like this.
Like in -- he was doing a
romantic thing.  And I said
the sound of today has
changed.  It has become very
(indiscernible).  But we need
to have our style, our
footprint on it.
So it took a while, probably
two, three months to get a
hybrid tone but still having
traditional stuff in it.  And
people liked it, I guess,
so....
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: And,
you know, of course, in
India, language is another
huge dimension.  So you have
composed music now for, you
know, films in a dozen
languages.  And sometimes,
you know, the same movie gets
released, of course, in many,
many different languages.
So how do you think about the
interaction between music and
the lyrics that you have put
into the modeldy?  How
Melody?  How many
languages do you speak, by
the way?
>>A.R. Rahman: I don't speak
any language properly.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Well.
>>A.R. Rahman: A little bit
of English, a little bit of
TILAGU.  Hindi I can sing,
but I can't speak.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>>A.R. Rahman: And I can
read a bit of Arabic.  So
those are the things.  I
tried to learn Mandarin, but
I --
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: And so
when you are, you know --
when you're --
>>A.R. Rahman: Your question
about --
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: The
lyrics, who writes them.
>>A.R. Rahman: So last year,
I had done Hindi, TAMIL,
Persian, and
Portuguese,
which is a movie coming next
year, based on PELE.  And a
Persian movie.
And then one movie was a
(indiscernible) movie, a
Hindi movie.  Yeah.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: And do
you have, then, people
translate some of the lyrics
that you write into these
other languages?  Do you hear
them?  How much do you --
>>A.R. Rahman: The director
works very close with the
lyric writer.
But what the song has to say
is one of my decisions, too.
The title of the song and the
notion of it, and -- so that
I work very closely, and the
rest of the stuff they fill
up beautifully.
And so half the -- it's a --
when you're working on a
movie, it's beautiful,
because if -- you have
competent people working.  We
kind of have a healthy
competition, and all of us
come to create one product,
which is beautiful.
Sometimes it works.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy:
That's -- well, I think it's
worked more than sometimes,
as we all can attest.
So I heard, by the way, that
you were at the White House
recently.
>>A.R. Rahman: Yeah. There
was a screening of (saying
name).
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: That's
amazing.  Did you get to meet
President Obama?  What was
that experience like?
>>A.R. Rahman: No. I met
him last time for the Indian
state dinner.  He was a big
fan of Slumdog.  They send me
Christmas cards.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Oh.
Woo-hoo!
[ Applause ]
Yeah.  He hasn't sent me any.
[ Laughter ]
How do you keep your energy
up?  You know, there is --
you said you did a concert
yesterday in L.A.  There's
the concert this evening in
San Jose.  You're traveling
in between.  How do you just
keep your energy up?
>>A.R. Rahman: All of it --
where I started and people
saw all the listings, they
were, like, what are you
going to do?  Are you going
to come back alive?
[ Laughter ]
So -- but -- so when you're
performing, it's a whole new
energy.  And different places
have different -- and people
make you regenerate it, the
kind of love they give.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: You get
that energy from the crowd?
>>A.R. Rahman: Amazing. So
far so good.  We just have
three more to go.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: How
many more?
>>A.R. Rahman: Three more
out of 18.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Okay.
So you're at the very end of
it.  That's amazing.  That is
amazing.
And, of course, you had a
number of celebrated
collaborations with many
different people.  Anything
that you would highlight as
being an amazingly special
experience, you know, a
movie, an actor, a singer,
one of the, you know, other
amazing folks like Mick
Jagger that you have
collaborated with?  What
stands out for you?
>>A.R. Rahman: I've been
very, very lucky.  I'm very
content, because I got --
first of all, one of my dream
directors worked with me for
the first film, ROJA.
Then I worked with Andrew
Lloyd Weber.  I worked with
(saying name), all of them
who I admired.
I worked with (saying name).
And just before he passed
away.
And I worked with Danny
BOYLE, very sympathetic
towards music.  And I just
met Terrence MALIC recently.
We just met.  He was based in
Austin.  He couldn't come for
the show, but he
(indiscernible) music.
And the one I want to work
with may be Stevie Wonder.
I have met him twice, but,
unfortunately, we couldn't
work together.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: That's
very cool.
So I think we are going to
now take questions that have
been submitted on the G+ page
and on YouTube.  So it will
be a mixture of questions
that we are going to play on
the monitor and things that
I'm going to read off that
were submitted to us via G+.
So the first question, which
is going to be on YouTube,
it's from, of all places,
Australia.  That's amazing.
From Australian fans Fred
Taylor and Daniel Lee.
Could we roll the video
number one, please.
>>> Hi. My name is Fred.
>>> My name is Daniel.
>>> We're from Australia, and
we're big fabs fans of your
work.
We've both got some questions
today.  My question is, can
you tell us more about your
latest technology that you
use when composing music.
>>> And on that note, I just
want to know how you feel
about the use of
(indiscernible).
>>> Thanks a
lot.
>>A.R. Rahman:
My philosophy
about using technology is,
you have to master them.  It
needs to work for you, and
you shouldn't work for that.
And so when I come to a
stage, if I'm using software,
I wait till I master it and
my thoughts go straight into
that rather than taking the
manual, oh, how do you use
this?  How do you edit?
So even if it takes two
years, I'll be in another
room, jamming with it.  And
one day, I'll say, guys,
change it, bring it to the
main room.  So that's been
going.
I used to work with hardware
sequences before.  And to
switch to logic, which is
what I'm using, Logic Pro, it
took two years.  I watched a
German programmer who worked
with me, (saying names), he
was using it, and a couple of
Australians were using it.
And it took me probably '97
or '98 is when I switched to
total software.
And so I'm using Logic Pro,
to answer your question,
and then we use PROTOSE for
mixing.  And then we use a
bit of (saying name) to add
harmnies and everything.
We use (indiscernible)
sometimes intentionally just
to give an effect.  Because
we have amazing singers.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: That's
cool.  I think that -- we all
see the inspiring work that
comes out.  But, clearly,
you're saying just to change
one instrument or one aspect
of the music, you literally
go through years of training
and practice.  I think there
is a lot to be learned there.
The second question is from
G+, from Google+.  And it's
from user Balaji T.  And his
question is, what is your
advice and motivation for
young people who want to
pursue a career in music?
With what amount of knowledge
and content does one break
through?
>>A.R. Rahman: I feel
whatever -- first of all, you
need to have an ear for
music.  You need to love
beautiful stuff.  Then it
becomes part of you.
It's even within spirituality
or music, the same thing, the
more you start getting into
something, and then it
becomes you.
And so if you're
halfheartedly doing something
and you don't give enough
time, it's not worth it.
But -- and you don't even
think about sustenance,
nothing, just go and do it
and become a master of it,
people will come following
you.  And that's the
truth.
[ Applause ]
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: That's
wonderful.
Next up, we have a video
question from Kevin Jenkinson
from Dublin, Ireland.
Let's roll video number two,
please.
[ Video ]
>>> Hi, Kevin Jenkinson here,
journalist in Dublin,
Ireland.  With the success of
Slumdog Millionaire and the
super bands, performing with
Mick Jagger, you've been a
global icon.  What is the one
wish you have for the world?
And how do you think your
fans can contribute to that
one wish globally?
>>A.R. Rahman: What is --
what did he say?
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: He's
saying what is the one wish
you have for the world and
how do you think your fans
can contribute to that one
wish globally?
>>A.R. Rahman:
There is a
lot of I would say impatience
with many things, you know.
Sometimes even on the table,
if your food comes late, you
start questioning and saying,
why did you bring it late and
starting trouble.  But you
can also be patient, you can
be calm, in the Zen mode, so
that you don't spoil the, you
know, aura of the place.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Yeah.
>>A.R. Rahman: And that
comes even in a major level.
And in a street, in a state,
in a country, in the world,
even on the net, you see
YouTube.  You just put
anything, and you have 30
comments down about the race,
about sex, about everything.
And it's so unfortunate.  And
then nobody wants to see the
video.  They want to see what
the comments are.
[ Laughter ]
They're so (indiscernible).
So I'm going to probably have
albums, comments are off.
Just listen to the music and
internalize it and speak to
yourself.
And to deal with many major
situations, I think we are
all judgmental, we are -- for
me, I think I'm judging
myself constantly.  So I
don't have time for judging
outside.
And that's the basic thing.
I think today's, if we are
more patient, then we are
more open and nonjudgmental,
I think the world would be a
better place.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: I love
that.  More patience, more
tolerance.  That's wonderful.
[ Applause ]
The next question is from
Ashutosh Gupta.  And he asks,
name the one album, by any
artist, that has influenced
and inspired you and your
music the
most.
>>A.R. Rahman: There is not
one.  There are many,
actually.
Peter Gabriel, John Williams,
and (saying names).  Then in
south India, we have (saying
names).  And north India,
NOSHAD, (saying name).
So if you look at the beauty
in everything, you -- as I
told you before, it affects
you in a good way.  And it
restarts all of you.  And
even music, it's very
important.      Rather than
shutting off and thinking --
and then you can go further
from there, where they left.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: That's
great.
And, you know, personally, I
think the loss of (saying
name) is one of the most
tragic things that's happened
to music in many, many years
at such a young age.
We have another YouTube
question.  This is from
Google intern Shailee Samar.
And she wants to know what
shaped your path when you
were younger.
Let's roll the video, please.
>>> Hi, my name is SHAILEE.
I'm 19 years old.  I'm one of
the very excited interns in
this audience.
When you were 19 years old,
what sorts of ideas,
thoughts, and dreams did you
have in your head and heart?
And how have those shaped you
to become who you are today?
>>A.R. Rahman: When I was
19, I was working, I
guess.
I was very confused.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't know whether anybody
would give a girl to me to
get married.
[ Laughter ]
Because I left school.  I
left high school.  I was
playing the studios.  And
there was constant gossip in
the studio that said music
and all the film industry
will end very soon, we will
go jobless.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: What
kept you going?
>>A.R. Rahman: There was no
other job I knew.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause
]
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: And
when did you really begin to
feel like what you are doing
was a profession, that --
something that you could, you
know, keep doing for a long
time?
>>A.R. Rahman: After the
first movie, after ROJA, I
think the whole
(indiscernible), and when I
realized I have to learn a
lot is when, you know, the
motivation to -- and I was
getting paid for learning.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: That's
right.  I mean, that's --
that's what the best jobs
have, which is what I tell my
children, for example.  It's
not a job if you love it.
And the fact that you get
paid for it just becomes,
like, this big bonus on the
side.
Next question is from
Srikanth Marthi.  This is
from G+.
How do you choose your
movies?  Based on the
director or the script?  And
she also says, since Slumdog,
your Indian film scores have
had a distinct international
flavor to them.  Was this a
conscious effort?  And will
you do a pure Indian album,
taking us back to our early
days?
>>A.R. Rahman: Many
questions.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Lots of
questions.  Four questions.
[ Laughter ]
Let's start with the simple
one.  How do you choose your
movies?  Is it the director?
Is it the script?
>>A.R. Rahman: I choose with
the necks of intention of a
team.  If
they have good intention and
they have done something good
before, at least I know they
are going to try to do
something good.  Most of the
times, it's good.  Sometimes
it goes down the wrong path.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: And
then the other ones were,
after you did Slumdog
Millionaire, your music has a
very international feel.  Is
this conscious?  Do you want
to, you know, go back --
>>A.R. Rahman: I think the
expectations were, like, if
you take iTunes or
anything, anybody can access
that music.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: That's
right.
>>A.R. Rahman: It doesn't
have to be, you know, certain
people.  If they want to
listen to my music.  So it
had to have a consistency in
it.  And maybe because of
that.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: And you
know, of course, you also
have a lot of fans on
YouTube.  How do you think
about YouTube as a medium?
I was checking your channel
last night.  You have, if I
remember correctly, something
like 150,000 subscribers to
your channel.  What do you
think of the medium.
>>A.R. Rahman: I think
YouTube is a blessing.
Because there was a
bottleneck before.  If
anybody was talented, they
had to go through sources,
and they -- oh, can you put
me on this thing, can you put
me on the cover.  Nobody
cares anymore.  Even --
they're good or bad, they put
it on YouTube.
[ Laughter ]
I discovered this dancer was
with us, called (saying
name), she's from Croatia.
And so I saw -- suddenly
stumbled on her.  And I said,
oh, she's good.  I know I was
doing a music video for my
assistant.  And I asked my
assistant, Vivian, to call
her.  And she said, A.R., I'm
Marilyn Monroe.  She never
believed that.
And, of course, I just got
on YouTube, JANITA, who is
singing this thing on
YouTube  .  Many people,
actually.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: That's
wonderful.  So you really are
seeing a lot of people,
amazing people, express
themselves through YouTube
and get discovered in ways
that have not really happened
before.
>>A.R. Rahman: They don't
have to count on anybody.
They can just do it.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Just do
it.
>>A.R. Rahman: It opens your
mind, gives a sense of....
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: And you
would consider, for example,
you know, broadcasting your
jam sessions just for people
to get inside, into how you
think and work?
>>A.R. Rahman: Just that
when you expose yourself too
much, they don't want you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause
]
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: I hear
that.  I hear that.
The next question is from
Halima Zaman, from
Bangladesh.
And she says, sometimes a
person is blessed with lots
of potential but doesn't have
support from their family.
What advice would you have
for them to follow and
fulfill their dream?
Was your family supportive,
by the way, when you wanted
to pursue music?
>>A.R. Rahman: Yeah. It was
opposite.  My mother wanted
me to do music, and I didn't
want to do music.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Oh.
What advice would you have
for her?
>>A.R. Rahman: I think she
should believe and pray, and
God will send somebody to
her.
That's what -- I feel that
there's always support,
biggest support.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Right,
right, right.
This is a good one.
This is from Prasanna
Ramachandran on G+.  And he
says, what's the one thing
about A.R. Rahman that nobody
knows yet?
[ Laughter ]
This might go back to your
too much exposure point.
[ Laughter ]
>>A.R. Rahman: I think
mostly everybody knows
everything about me.  Maybe
my --
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Your
life's an open book.
>>A.R. Rahman: My wife
should say something.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: We have
a question from YouTube
now.  This is from Somas
Thyagaraja.  And he wants to
know more about the creation
process.  I think that's the
thing that we are all
fascinated by.  How does this
amazing processor of process of
such
beautiful music happen.
>>> My question for you today
is I've always been curious
how you come up with these
amazing songs one after the
other for 25 years.  I'm
curious to hear right from
the inception of the track
and the basic tune that you
have, how do you develop that
into the final song that we
all get to hear?  It would be
great if you can share, you
know, your experiences from,
like, a couple of memorable
tracks of how it came about
and how you ended up with
that final magic that we all
get to hear.  I'm sure
millions of people in the
world would love to hear that
as well.
Thank you so much.
>>A.R. Rahman: No, like an
artist, who reflects whatever
is inside on a painting,
music is also like that.  If
I am in a Zen mode, if I am
peaceful, and then the music
which comes out mirrors it.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: So do
you have to get angry to --
>>A.R. Rahman: No. I just
need to put a beat and start
playing with it.
Mostly, I don't do stuff like
that in dark.  I don't know
why.  The world is, anyway,
dark.
So then what I do is, I do a
lot of ideas, and probably
two sessions or three
sessions, have 20 ideas.
It's very, very important to
have a lot of ideas.  And
then listen to it back and
compare it to my work and
compare it to greater works
which you've heard before,
where does it stand.  So what
does it take to make it
beautiful.
So if it's very simple as a
tune, then the arrangement
actually implements it in
complements it in a
different way.  If you have
both together, you get a
beautiful lyric.      So
there are many, many stages
where you can achieve.  Still
it's not good, you throw it
off and do something else.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: How
often do you end up
discarding melodies and songs
which you have created.
>>A.R. Rahman: 5%.
Sometimes we do a song and I
say, no, I don't like it.  If
you're trying too hard, I
don't think it's worth it.
It has to come fresh.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Right,
right.
What do you see in the future
for you, next five years?
What are things that you
would like to get done?
>>A.R. Rahman: There are
many things, actually.  After
starting the school, the
college, we have amazing
talent --
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Tell us
a little bit about this
college.  I don't think we
know.
>>A.R. Rahman: The college
started in 2008.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Yep.
>>A.R. Rahman: It has a
conservatory.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: This is
in Chennai?
>>A.R. Rahman: In Chennai.
The idea was to give the best
training in classical and
Hindustani.
So we have -- we've been
doing it five years.  We
opened a campus now two years
back.  (indiscernible) came
and opened it up.
And the main motive is to
give the kids who want to
learn music something unique
which India doesn't give.
And to get underprivileged
kids to -- to make them
trained in classical.
Because for studio musicians,
studio work, we don't have
string players or brass
players or anything.  The
previous generation is there.
But the younger generation
don't want to learn that.  So
probably in a few years,
we'll have an orchestra then.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: So this
is -- this is, like --
>>A.R. Rahman: In fact, we
have one on YouTube.  It's
called the sunshine
orchestra.      You can check
it out.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Okay.
>>A.R. Rahman: It was based
on that.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: And
these students go through a
structured curriculum?  Is --
so --
>>A.R. Rahman: Yes.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: So this
is not the traditional, like
the (saying name).
>>A.R. Rahman: No. We have
teachers from Armenia,
Scotland, the U.S., U.K., all
over the place.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Wow.
And how big is this?  How
many students are part of the
school?
>>A.R. Rahman: It's -- I
think we have around 200, 300
students.  And the campus is
around 40,000 square feet.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Okay.
That's a big campus.  That's
wonderful.  That's really
wonderful.
And --
>>A.R. Rahman: So the
question is because we have
this access to all these
beautiful things.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Yeah.
>>A.R. Rahman: My -- my part
would be to write more
things.  I will probably set
up musicals, coming from the
product of the conservatory.
So India can watch
something unique coming from
our culture, yet having the
sensibilities of whatever any
of us would like.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: and how
do you see Indian music
evolving?  Of course, you are
in -- you know, you are in
Chennai, which is also the
heart of things like CARNATIC
music, which continues to be
a very vibrant art form.  How
do you see Indian music
itself evolving, again, over
the next several years?
>>A.R. Rahman: Things are
opening up, I think.  You can
see a lot of innovative
things starting to come.  I
think when that goes to the
next stage, I think I feel
there will be something in
it.  Right now, it's still in
a shell, I feel.  Classical
music -- it has to be
protected.  But some people
can be more liberal and then
can go and do some wilder
things without spoiling the
sanctity of it.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: I think
you have done an amazing job
of being innovative, of
pushing boundaries, of
blending things in a way that
all of us have felt reflects
who we are as people.  I
think that's part of what is
amazing about your music.
>>A.R. Rahman: I get bored.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: What's
that?
>>A.R. Rahman: I get bored
of the same thing.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: We are
happy, because your music
keeps changing.  It keeps
engaging us.  So I think that
is wonderful.
So this is actually a great
segue to the last part of the
show.  I am told that you're
going to do a little
performance for us.
[ Cheers and applause
]
>>A.R. Rahman: Yeah. If you
want to hear us all sing, you
should come to the show.
[ Laughter ]
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: We'll
be there.
>>A.R. Rahman: Okay. Sure.
It's -- last night was wild,
actually.  Very nice people.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Lots of
audience participation?
>>A.R. Rahman: Yeah.
Beautiful.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: We look
forward to that.
>>A.R. Rahman: What's this?
Oh.
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Please
give him a big round of
applause again.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
>>A.R. Rahman:
(indiscernible) what I am
doing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>>A.R. Rahman: That's it.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>>Sridhar Ramaswamy: Thank
you, A.R. for coming.  We are